[Musique]
quand gérard un regard sur le monde je
le regarde j'essaye de le regarder avec
toute l'objectivité possible bien que je
ne crois pas que l'objectivité puisse
exister mais il ya quand même des
éléments qui nous permettent de
comprendre et d'analyser et à partir de
là et bien j'essaye de 2 me de
construire quand même quelque chose
c'est à dire que je suis on peut dire
que je suis si vous voulez optimiste
parce que je crois je crois qu'à la fois
la force de la vie je crois que nous
êtres humains nous avons nous avons
beaucoup plus de moyens que nous pensons
pour inverser des situations qui nous
paraissent absolument dramatique qui
nous paraît sans issue nous sommes
parfaitement capables de trouver de
nouvelles issues nous en avons le
pouvoir et mon rôle ne consiste pas à
dire je suis pessimiste je suis
optimiste mais a essayé de a essayé en
quelque sorte à à mon modeste niveau
d'aiguillonner un petit peu les
consciences pour dire écoutez non voyez
le bateau coule mais nous sommes
capables de colmater nous sommes capable
de découper nous sommes capables de
redonner une direction et un sens à
cette espèce de comment dire de démarche
complètement du livre de cette planète
livre vert dont on ne sait plus où elle
va
nous pouvons parfaitement à donner un
sens
[Musique]